the movie opens with siblings Peter and
Annie Garrett climbing a rock with their
dad Royce in Monument Valley Utah they
happily discuss SS from different eras
while climbing showing that they are all
experienced climbers suddenly a distress
call comes from a climber above followed
by a falling backpack the three manag to
dodge the backpack but soon the two
climbers above them fall down too this
causes Roy Peter and Annie to be swept
off their safety harnesses leaving all
the five climbers dangling by a single
rope the Rope is now held to the Rock C
by a single safety harness as Roy tries
to con everyone down the two climbers
below him fall down leaving just the
father and the siblings on the Rope Roy
instructs Annie to secure them to the
wall but realizes the safety harness is
slipping out of the crevice knowing the
single harness won't hold their weight
Roy makes a tough decision and asks
Peter to cut him loose an he pleads with
Peter not to but Roy insists that if he
doesn't cut the rope quickly they'll all
die Peter horrified by what he's about
to do cuts the Rope with his knife and
Roy Falls to to his death 3 years after
the accident Peter is taking photos of
two rare snow leopards in the Hills near
Mount K2 for National Geographic as the
weather worsens he starts heading back
down the mountain with his Porter
unfortunately the porter falls and
breaks his leg Peter quickly takes the
injured Porter to a Pakistani military
helicopter that is going to a hospital
in sain Glacier to deliver medical
supplies as the helicopter flies away a
Sports Illustrated magazine blows out of
a nearby tent the cover features Annie
Garrett as one of the best climbers of
her time on the helicopter ride the
pilot major rassle tells Peter that he
will drop him off at Mount K2 base camp
on the way back from the hospital he
then reveals that Annie is also at the
base camp since the accident in Monument
Valley the relationship between the two
siblings rarely communicate with each
other upon reaching the glacier Peter is
shocked to discover that the hospital is
only receiving 25% of the total medical
supplies delivered by the helicopter the
remaining supplies are being diverted to
a massive 40-man team led by American
billionaire Elliot vaugh who has brought
them to K2 on the return trip from the
hospital major rassle informs Peter that
Annie is heading a WN documentary team
up K2 which is being funded by vaugh
upon further inquiry Peter learns that
vau attempted to Summit K2 from the
south face 4 years ago however due to a
severe weather change his Ascent was cut
short just 800 M from the peak despite
enduring a harrowing night in the death
zone vau managed to descend the next day
demonstrating his exceptional climbing
skills upon reaching the base camp Peter
is greeted rather awkwardly by his
sister Annie she reveals that they are
leaving tomorrow and they plan to Summit
the mountain within 2: p.m. on Wednesday
much to the surprise of Peter Peter asks
if anyone could schedule summiting a
mountain and suggests that the climbing
party should slowly Summit the mountain
after a climatization and constant
checking of weather in response Annie
scoffs off and curtly replies that she
trusts and admires V's plan the base
camp is a buzz with a varied cast of
characters including two naked hippies
Malcolm and sirel bench lounging by the
fire seemingly under the influence of
alcohol a ragged long-haired old man
emerges from his tent to witness two
helicopters descending upon the base
camp stepping out of the helicopter
amidst much fanfare and media attention
is Vincent vaugh he warmly greets an
Antony McLaren a celebrated Mountaineer
with a remarkable collection of Records
in the mountaineering World meanwhile
Peter encounters skip who operates a
struggling Mountain guiding company and
his manager and medic manique skip
informs Peter of V's ambitious plan to
Summit K2 precisely at the moment when
the inaugural flight of his new Airline
Majestic flights Soares over the peak
creating a captivating photo opportunity
that night V hosts a lively party at the
base camp where he openly shares his
remorse Over The Misfortune that halted
his previous Summit attempt 4 years ago
with unwavering confidence he reiterates
his audacious plan to ascend to the peak
in a short amount of time amidst the
boisterous cheers and Applause the en
Matic long-haired bearded man from
earlier emerges from the crowd and
boldly confronts vau about his
ill-conceived plan this grizzled
Mountaineer is none other than
Montgomery Wick a former Army comrade of
Peter and Annie's father interestingly
Wick holds the extraordinary record of
summitting K2 in a remarkable 24 hours
despite Wick's intimidating presence and
direct challenge V's smooth rhetoric and
charm enable him to deflect the
questions allowing the party to continue
unabated later under the cloak of
Darkness Wick shaves his beard and off
towards the mountain meanwhile Peter
seeks out his sister Annie in her tent
where their simmering tensions erupt
Annie still grappling with the weight of
their father's death holds Peter
accountable for his demise she confronts
him questioning his decision to abandon
climbing with a tearful farewell Peter
wishes his sister well and departs the
day of the ascent comes and V's teammate
of Annie McLaren himself Mountaineer Ali
Nazir and one other bid their base
support team farewell as Peter watches
the helicopters fly away he notices a a
small Stone memorial for Mayon the wick
Montgomery's late wife as the climbing
party ascends K2 first vau and then
McLaren noticed Spindrift blowing off
the mountain Summit in the high
mountains Spindrift is a sign of an
approaching storm and potential
Avalanche so McLaren contacts the base
team for a weather update he learns that
a storm is brewing that could
potentially reach their location but
Annie suggests they continue climbing as
the storm might head east away from them
McLaren argues that he cannot risk a
storm at 26 feet for a publicity stunt
to which vau replies that he doesn't
care about the publicity he only wants
to Summit the mountain because this is
their only chance reluctantly the party
presses on continuing their Ascent of
the Mountain at the base station the
support team receives alarming weather
updates the winds are intensifying the
pressure is dropping and clouds are
rapidly approaching the climbing party
meteorologist Max urges the base team to
instruct the climbers to descend
immediately but Frank Williams the head
of Von's base team stubbornly insists on
proceeding with the summit attempt enter
Peter who identifies himself as Annie's
brother he expresses his concern about
the rising winds and the impending storm
despite Frank's dismissive attitude Max
reiterates that the data confirms the
imminent arrival of severe weather
horrified Peter forcefully seizes the
radio control system and contacts Tom
McLaren warning him of an approaching
major storm from the south Tom
unfamiliar with Peter dismisses his
warning until skip intervenes warning
Tom to descend immediately or face grave
Danger acknowledging Skip's credibility
Tom orders everyone to begin their
descent however vau manages to
manipulate Tom into keeping the climb
going by labeling skip as a second class
Hustler who wishes he could be in Tom's
Shoes the storm suddenly arrives forcing
Tom to descend followed by a disgruntled
vaugh however before they can secure
their footing in the Raging blizzard
Annie slips into a crass pulling Elliot
vaugh with her to make matters worse an
avalanche slams into the area sweeping
McLaren into the crass and killing the
other two climbers in in their party
McLaren survives the fall with severe
injuries but they lose contact with the
base camp back at the base camp a somber
mood prevails as attempts to establish
contact with the climbers prove feudal
however Peter devises an ingenious plan
to connect with his sister through Morse
code using the damaged radio signal
Annie successfully receives the message
much to the relief of both vau and
McLaren with this breakthrough the base
camp receives confirmation that at least
three climbers Annie vaugh and McLaren
are alive and trapped in the crevice
Peter immediately takes charge
formulating a rescue plan to save them
he proposes acquiring explosive
nitroglycerin canisters from the
Pakistani army to Aid in clearing the
crevice for Access initially everyone
except skip hesitates to join the rescue
mission due to the extreme risks and
tight timeline undeterred Peter outlines
a plan to execute a rapid Ascent in
pairs with each pair carrying a single
Nitro glycerin canister in the crass vau
meticulously divides The Limited
supplies they have left half a cup of of
water for each person every 2 hours
followed by fuel cells to melt water
from Ice and finally dexamethason
syringes as a last resort insufficient
water could lead to deadly pulmonary
edema back at the base camp facing the
urgency of Time Peter devises a plan to
send a rescue team via helicopter to an
altitude of 21 ft giving them a mere 22
hours to locate and rescue the survivors
skip recommends enlisting Montgomery
wick for the rescue mission revealing
Wick's heroic Act 4 years ago during
that Summit attempt a nine-member
American climbing team including Elliot
vaugh and Wick's wife lost their way
despite knowing he couldn't save his
wife Wick ventured up the mountain alone
and miraculously rescued three fellow
climbers enduring severe frostbite that
resulted in the loss of his toes such
unwavering determination is precisely
what they need now after careful
consideration and a half million doll
check from Frank Williams a rescue team
is assembled Peter skip Brothers Malcolm
and sirel bench and manique they locate
WI a tent high up on the mountain and
plead with him to join the Expedition
initially reluctant Wick agrees upon
learning that vau will be part of the
rescue effort however Wick quickly
establishes his authority instructing
skip to return to base due to his
distrust of Von's team Wick then pairs
sirel with manique Malcolm with kareim
who is Ali nazar's cousin and finally
himself with Peter in the next scene we
see that the rescue team has a near
fatal airdrop at 21 ft after which they
split up taking different rats to find
the survivors the scene shifts to the
survivors in the crass where McLaren is
visibly struggling Von coldly suggests
not wasting the precious dexamethasone
syringes on McLaren claiming that
there's no way the rescuers can carry
him down from that altitude Annie
vehemently opposes this plan reminded of
the incident in Monument Valley and
McLaren also refuses to accept his fate
meanwhile Peter finds it difficult to
match Wick's pace and they engage in a
heated argument when Peter realizes that
Wick's primary motivation is revenge
against vau rather than the rescue
itself a little later Wick manages to
establish contact with the vaugh despite
their differences and vaugh informs him
that Annie is starting to show signs of
Eda tensions escalate within the crass
as Annie exhibits early symptoms of
pulmonary edema vau blames Tom for this
accusing him of allowing Annie to inject
herself with a dexamethasone syringe
prematurely Kong counters that Von could
easily give Annie one of his syringes
since he's not yet sick but vau
stubbornly refuses determined to save
herself and Tom Annie embarks on a
paress mission to cross to the other
side of the crevice and retrieve Alli
nazir's backpack despite narrowly
escaping death she successfully
retrieves the backpack and discovers
four more dexamethason syringes she
immediately injects herself and Tom much
to Von's disapproval amidst the harsh
terrain manique and sirel encounter a
devastating setback when sirel loses his
footing causing the nitroglycerin
canister to plummet down a steep rock
face the resulting explosion triggers an
avalanche tragically sweeping sirel to
his death manique barely Escaping The
avalanche's Wrath manages to rejoin
Peter and Wick news reaches the base
team that the nitroglycerin canisters
are highly volatile and prone to
explosions even when stored within
secure containers upon receiving this
critical information skip alerts Wick
who promptly instructs Peter to move
their canister into the shade they also
manag to warn Malcolm and kareim who
hastily move their canister as well
unfortunately they failed to notice a
leak developing in their canister as the
nitroglycerin seeps out comes into
contact with sunlight it ignites in a
catastrophic explosion claiming the
lives of both Kareem and Malcolm the
blast also triggers a shift in the ice
exposing the frozen body of a woman the
woman is none other than Montgomery
Wick's wife Peter discovers an empty
dexamethason box near the body
confirming Wick's suspicion that vaugh
had stolen his wife's syringes
abandoning her to her fate despite
Peter's please Wick admits to his thirst
for vengeance against vau recognizing
Wick's vengeful nature Peter and manique
make the decision ision to leave the
next morning without him at the crass
vau taking advantage of Annie's
exhaustion uses an airfill syringe to
kill McLaren upon Awakening Annie
discovers the empty syringe next to
McLaren's lifeless body and confronts
vau with their oxygen levels rapidly
deading they realize that their time is
running out unless The Rescuers arrive
soon as their lungs begin to fill with
fluid Annie and vau desperately Mark the
crass entrance by placing a flare inside
a bag of mcclaren's blood and detonating
it after a caress leap across a ridge
Peter and manique spot the Crimson
stained crass entrance and hastily
secure their nitroglycerin canister to
blast a larger opening they lower a rope
and vau with Annie attached signals
Peter and manique to pull her up however
as Annie nears the surface the pickaxe
secured to the Rope starts to slip from
the ice causing her to plummet back down
just in the nick of time Wick arrives
and joins the exhausted Peter and
manique in their rescue efforts Wick
descends into the crass and a frightened
vaugh seizes a pickaxe in self defense
fearing Wick's vengeful intentions after
a brief struggle Wick manages to attach
a clip to vaugh ensuring his rescue as
well with Wick below assisting manique
and Peter gradually lift Annie upwards
unfortunately Annie's leg gets caught in
a boulder which comes crashing down onto
the ledge where Wick and vaugh are
standing as a result Annie Peter Wick
and vaugh find themselves dangling
precariously by a single rope eerily
reminiscent of the opening scene in a
stark contrast to the earlier incident
Peter doesn't face the agonizing
decision of cutting the Rope this time
instead Wick determined to execute his
revenge pulls out his knife and severs
the Rope Wick and Von plummet into the
depths of the Cass meeting their demise
the film concludes at the base camp
where the survivors have gathered after
3 years of estrangement Annie and Peter
finally mend their relationship Nique
and Peter share a kiss as the camera
pans towards the memorials erected in
honor of those who perish during the
Rescue Mission